[Music]
in March of 1892 three black grocery
store owners in Memphis Tennessee were
murdered by a mob of white men lynchings
like these were happening all over the
American South often without any
subsequent legal investigation or
consequences for the murderers but this
time a young journalist and friend of
the victims set out to expose the truth
about these killings her reports would
shock the nation and launch her career
as an investigative journalist civic
leader and civil rights advocate her
name was Ida B wells
idabelle Wells was born into slavery in
Holly Springs Mississippi on July 16th
1862 several months before the
Emancipation Proclamation released her
and her family after losing both parents
and a brother to yellow fever at the age
of 16 she supported her five remaining
siblings by working as a schoolteacher
in Memphis Tennessee during this time
she began working as a journalist
writing under the pen name
Iola by the early 1890s she gained a
reputation as a clear voice against
racial injustice and became co-owner and
editor of the Memphis free speech and
headlight newspaper she had no shortage
of material in the decades following the
Civil War Southern whites attempted to
reassert their power by committing
crimes against black people including
suppressing their votes vandalizing
their businesses and even murdering them
after the murder of her friends Welles
launched an investigation into lynching
she analyzed specific cases through
newspaper reports and police records and
interviewed people who had lost friends
and family to lynch mobs she risked her
life to get this information as a black
person investigating racially motivated
murders she enraged many of the same
southern white men involved in lynchings
her bravery paid off most White's had
claimed and subsequently reported that
lynchings were responses to criminal
acts by black people but that was not
usually the case through her research
well showed that these murders were
actually a deliberate brutal tactic to
control or punish black people who
competed with White's her friends for
example had been lynched when their
grocery store became popular enough to
divert business from a white competitor
Wells published her findings in 1892 in
response a white mob destroyed her
newspaper presses she was out of town
when they struck but they threatened to
kill her if she ever returned to Memphis
so she traveled to New York where that
same year she republished her research
in a pamphlet titled southern Horrors
lynch law in all its phases in 1895
after settling in Chicago she built on
southern Horrors and a longer piece
called
the red record her careful documentation
of the horrors of lynching and
impassioned public speeches drew
international attention wells used her
newfound fame to amplify her message she
traveled to Europe where she rallied
European outrage against racial violence
in the American South in hopes that the
US government and public would follow
their example back in the u.s. she
didn't hesitate to confront powerful
organizations fighting the
segregationist policies of the YMCA and
leading a delegation to the White House
to protest discriminatory workplace
practices she did all this while
disenfranchised herself women didn't win
the right to vote until Welles was in
her late 50s and even then the vote was
primarily extended to white women only
Welles was a key player in the battle
for voting inclusion starting a black
woman's suffrage organization in Chicago
but in spite of her deep commitment to
women's rights
she clashed with white leaders of the
movement during a March for women's
suffrage in Washington DC she ignored
the organizers attempt to placate
southern bigotry by placing black women
in the back and marched up front
alongside the white women she also
chafed with other civil rights leaders
who saw her as a dangerous radical she
insisted on airing in full detail the
atrocities taking place in the south
while others thought doing so would be
counterproductive to negotiations with
white politicians although she
participated in the founding of the
n-double a-c-p
she was soon sidelined from the
organization Welles unwillingness to
compromise any aspect of her vision of
justice shined a light on the weak
points of the various rights movements
and ultimately made them stronger but
also made it difficult for her to find a
place within them
she was ahead of her time waging a
tireless struggle for equality and
justice decades before many had even
begun to imagine it possible if you were
inspired by ITB wells fight for equality
check out this playlist for more videos
about influential women throughout
history
[Music]